in a class like that
with more than 150 other kids,
and for six years.
In this time, it just happened to me to come to school
to realize that my classmate died.
Today, not so much has changed.
There is still no electricity in my village.
People still are dying in Burkina Faso,
and access to clean drinking water
is still a big problem.
I had luck. I was lucky, because this is a fact of life
when you grow up in a place like that.
But I was lucky.
I had a scholarship.
I could go to Germany to study.
So now, I suppose,
I don't need to explain to you how great a privilege
it is for me to be standing before you today.
From Gando, my home village in Burkina Faso,
to Berlin in Germany to become an architect
is a big, big step.
But what to do with this privilege?
Since I was a student, I wanted to open up
better opportunities to other kids in Gando.
I just wanted to use my skills and build a school.
But how do you do it when you're still a student
and you don't have money?
Oh yes, I started to make drawings
and asked for money.
Fundraising was not an easy task.
I even asked my classmates
to spend less money on coffee and cigarettes,
but to sponsor my school project.
In real wonder, two years later,
I was able to collect 50,000 U.S. dollars.
When I came home to Gando
to bring the good news,
my people were over the moon,
but when they realized
that I was planning to use clay,
they were shocked.
"A clay building is not able to stand a rainy season,
and Francis wants us to use it and build a school.
Is this the reason why he spent so much time
in Europe studying
instead of working in the field with us?"
My people build all the time with clay,
but they don't see any innovation with mud.
So I had to convince everybody.
I started to speak with the community,
and I could convince everybody,
and we could start to work.
And the women, the men,
everybody from the village,
was part of this building process.
I was allowed to use even traditional techniques.
So clay floor for example,
the young men come and stand like that, beating,
hours for hours,
and then their mothers came,
and they are beating in this position,
for hours, giving water and beating.
And then the polishers come.
They start polishing it with a stone for hours.
And then you have this result,
very fine, like a baby bottom.
(Laughter)
It's not photoshopped. (Laughter)
This is the school, built with the community.
The walls are totally made out
of compressed clay blocks from Gando.
The roof structure is made
with cheap steel bars
normally hiding inside concrete.
And the classroom, the ceiling is made
out of both of them used together.
In this school, there was a simple idea:
to create comfort in a classroom.
Don't forget, it can be 45 degrees in Burkina Faso,
so with simple ventilation,
I wanted to make the classroom
good for teaching and learning.
And this is the project today,
12 years old, still in best condition.
And the kids, they love it.
And for me and my community,
this project was a huge success.
It has opened up opportunities
to do more projects in Gando.
So I could do a lot of projects,
and here I am going to share with you
only three of them.
The first one is the school extension, of course.
How do you explain drawings and engineering
to people who are neither able to read nor write?
I started to build a prototype like that.
The innovation was to build a clay vault.
So then, I jumped on the top like that,
with my team, and it works.
The community is looking. It still works.
So we can build. (Laughter)
And we kept building, and that is the result.
The kids are happy, and they love it.
The community is very proud. We made it.
And even animals, like these donkeys,
love our buildings.
(Laughter)
The next project is the library in Gando.
And see now, we tried to introduce
different ideas in our buildings,
but we often don't have so much material.
Something we have in Gando are clay pots.
We wanted to use them to create openings.
So we just bring them like you can see
to the building site.
we start cutting them,
and then we place them on top of the roof
before we pour the concrete,
and you have this result.
The openings are letting the hot air out
and light in.
Very simple.
My most recent project in Gando
is a high school project.
I would like to share with you this.
The innovation in this project
is to cast mud like you cast concrete.
How do you cast mud?
We start making a lot of mortars, like you can see,
and when everything is ready,
when you know what is the best recipe
and the best form,
you start working with the community.
And sometimes I can leave.
They will do it themselves.
I came to speak to you like that.
Another factor in Gando is rain.
When the rains come,
we hurry up to protect our fragile walls
against the rain.
Don't confound with Christo and Jeanne-Claude.
It is simply how we protect our walls.
(Laughter)
The rain in Burkina comes very fast,
and after that, you have floods
everywhere in the country.
But for us, the rain is good.
It brings sand and gravel to the river
we need to use to build.
We just wait for the rain to go.
We take the sand, we mix it with clay,
and we keep building.
That is it.
The Gando project was always connected to training the people,
because I just wanted, one day
when I fall down and die,
that at least one person from Gando
keeps doing this work.
But you will be surprised. I'm still alive.
(Laughter)
And my people now can use their skills
to earn money themselves.
Usually, for a young man from Gando to earn money,
you have to leave the country
to the city, sometimes leave the country
and some never come back,
making the community weaker.
But now they can stay in the country
and work on different building sites
and earn money to feed their family.
There's a new quality in this work.
Yes, you know it.
I have won a lot of awards through this work.
For sure, it has opened opportunities.
I have become myself known.
But the reason why I do what I do
is my community.
When I was a kid,
I was going to school,
I was coming back every holiday to Gando.
By the end of every holidays,
I had to say goodbye to the community,
going from one compound to another one.
All women in Gando will open their clothes like that
and give me the last penny.
In my culture, this is a symbol of deep affection.
As a seven-year-old guy, I was impressed.
I just asked my mother one day,
"Why do all these women love me so much?"
(Laughter)
She just answered,
"They are contributing to pay for your education
hoping that you will be successful
and one day come back and help
improve the quality of life of the community."
I hope now that I was able to make my community proud
through this work,
and I hope I was able to prove you the power
of community,
and to show you that architecture
can be inspiring for communities
to shape their own future.
Merci beaucoup. (Applause)
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. (Applause)